1 mardi soir au divan orange un gros
méconnu du grand public se produit
devant quelques dizaines de personnes
dans la petite salle de concert du
boulevard saint-laurent qui est sur le
point de fermer ses portes
c'est très triste pour montréal et c'est
une belle place pour la culture pour
tous les musiciens le divan orange met
fin à ses activités en raison de
problèmes financiers
ici les artistes paix entre 100 et 200
dollars pour monter sur scène ils
récoltent la totalité des recettes
provenant des ventes de billets à la
porte
l'unique source de financement de la
salle de spectacle et la vente d'alcool
et ce n'est pas toujours rentable mais
le divan orange se voit avant tout comme
un lieu de diffusion pour les artistes
émergents et non comme un simple bar et
défendra patrick watson qui revient en
temps on a coeur de pirate qui a fait
son premier show ici puis stephen
sarments la salle la plus bond et et ça
ça veut dire que pour sa baie nous faut
accepter le fait qu'il va peut-être
avoir trente personnes comme 200
personnes mais font vivre avec ce qu'il
faut soutenir les choix 30 personnes
parce que ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont
mauvais ou qui valent pas la peine
patrick watson coeur de pirate yann
perreau à von roll la liste des artistes
qui ont foulé les planches de divan
orange et qui ont réussi à percer et
longue
je me souviens très bien comme de la
première fois où je suis allé porter un
démon divan orange puis c'est comme mon
rêve de jouer
un rêve de cloper le gag a finalement
réalisé à plusieurs reprises
elle y a même tourné un vidéoclip c'est
un lieu de diffusion qui était hyper
hyper important qui permit à printemps
plein de gens moi y compris de faire ses
premiers pas de spectacle puis qui
offrait des conditions assez agréable
pour des gens qui avait pas de public
qui nécessairement c'est comme un
laboratoire pour un parti c'est le divan
la casa del popolo le lion d'or tout le
monde doit jouer des salles comme ça
avant des catadores de pouvoir monter un
gros show et donc ses salles font partie
intégrante d'un écosystème contrairement
aux salles de spectacles traditionnels
le divan orange ne peut obtenir de
subventions gouvernementales
ces artisans souhaitent que la fermeture
de l'endroit provoque une réflexion on
rentre pas dans le système c'est yvon
dit on et vous êtes sur un bar et une
salle de spectacle
je crois qu'il faut quand même tous
s'asseoir ensemble et trouver une
manière de reconnaître c'est quoi une
petite salle de spectacle il y en a
juste pas d'équivalent au divan orange
habitués de l'endroit
laurent saulnier crois que certains
organismes culturels qui subventionne
déjà des concours musicaux pourrait
offrir de l'aide financière aux petites
salles de spectacles comme le divan
orange est ce que ces organismes le
plutôt que d'aider les gens qui passent
par le chemin des concots voudrez pas
aider un lieu comme le divan rouge qui
est tout aussi utile à la relève à
l'émergence à l'éclosion de nouveaux
talents
mais pour le divan orange il est déjà
trop tard la fermeture est irrévocable
ici olivier bachand à radio canada
montréal
[Musique]